as the 2020 race heats up to be a battle
over whose mother washed more floors for
less money we ask when victimhood became
a substitute for virtue fortunately we
are joined by Peter Bogosian and Jim
Lindsay authors of the infamous
grievance studies experiment that got
papers on human reactions to rape
culture and queer performativity at
urban dog parks in Portland Oregon
published in peer-reviewed academic
journals then Kamala Harris flip-flops
on medicare-for-all in record time
she really is Hillary 4.0 finally some
bad pop culture and voter fraud in Texas
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
new date new time our next episode of
daily wire backstage has been
rescheduled for the evening of February
5th daily wire god-king Jeremy boring
Ben Shapiro and reclaim and Alicia crass
and little ol me will be smokin stogies
breaking down the issues of the day
separating the Magga from the non Magga
and enjoying those sweet sweet delicious
leftist tears will we finally see
president Trump deliver the State of the
Union I don't know maybe tune in on
Tuesday to find out as always only daily
wire subscribers get to ask the
questions so make sure to subscribe
today lot to get to today the howard
schultz for president campaign is
rolling along beautifully it is creating
big divisions within the Democrat Party
it is causing Kamala Harris to
immediately switch up her strategy for
2020 and it's all leading toward
victimhood
and grievance Howard Schultz just
doesn't get it but our guests coming up
Peter Berg Ocean and Jim Lindsay do
first let me tell you about spear will
make a little money honey listen when
you write I know this better than
anybody sometimes you're just staring at
a blank page now for some of us this
becomes a best-selling book but for
others it's really frustrating and it's
called writer's block spear fixes this
spear is not a word processor primarily
it is a thought processor and that blank
page is not a very good thought
processor but spear helps you organize
your thoughts you can move it around
it's ingenious I really like it I've
been using it myself most people hate
writing because they can't organize
their thoughts a spear can make that
happen it's like working with Legos
forwards all your content is auto saved
backed up and encrypted you can create
your best written work for articles
books documents or whatever else you
dream up a lot of people write in to me
they say they have trouble writing
columns or writing blogs or running a
book they want to know how to get
started spear is a great way to get
started because it will make organizing
your thoughts so much easier this week
my listeners can get spear for just
$3.75 per month for your first year of
service that's a 25% discount off the
regular price sign up today by going to
spear comm slash Knowles KO wles
that is spear with an e like who like
Shakespeare if you don't know that then
organize your thought
Lotso you know come on man get on it
with spear check it out spear comm slash
Knowles okay
the howard schultz for president
campaign could not possibly be going
better howard schultz was on MSNBC he's
discussing his independent bid for
president he's been a lifelong democrat
but the democrat party has moved very
far left he could never win the Democrat
primary today so he's running as an
independent this is a billionaire and
already Democrats are throwing tomatoes
at him they don't want him to run they
hate him he's a plutocrat he's a
billionaire he's a straight white man
here is how Howard Schultz responds why
not just run as a Democrat we know you
are a Democrat you've given to Hillary
Clinton yeah you've snow I've seen what
it hurt I have seen in a Democrat but I
sorry you no longer a Democrat I'm not a
Democrat I don't affiliate myself the
Democratic Party whose so far left who
basically wants the government to take
over a health care which we cannot
afford the government to give free
college to everybody and the government
to give everyone a job which basically
is 40 trillion dollars on the balance
sheet of 21 and a half trillion dollars
we can't afford it what can we do what
we need is comprehensive tax reform
what we need is sensible solutions to
immigration all of these things cannot
happen under the current environment now
I've also been criticized for being a
billionaire let's talk about that
I'm self-made I grew up in the projects
in Brooklyn New York I thought that was
the American dream the aspiration of
America you're gonna criticize me for
being successful yes yes I'm not gonna
criticize you for being successful but
the Democrats will criticize you for
being successful because the left gets
everything backwards we've talked about
this for weeks now on the show it's
become clearer every day the left gets
at all backwards to a large portion of
America being a self-made billionaire is
not the dream for a large portion of
America to the left the American dream
is to be the most aggrieved it is to be
the biggest victim to check off all the
victimhood boxes that is the dream that
is what people are trying to do now
there are a lot of people who were born
into immense privilege who pretend that
they weren't
great example this is Alexandria Ocasio
cortez she grew up in a nicer town than
I did she grew up right next door to
where I did a very affluent County one
of the richest in the country she grew
up there from the age five all the way
up through college he attended a private
college
according to her voting records she
lived in ritzy Northern Westchester
until just two years ago and what does
she do she pretends she's Jenny from the
block it's not my phrase she tweets it
out she says I'm still I'm still Alex
from the Bronx she's pretending that
she's had a worse upbringing a worse
education of more difficult aggrieved
experience of life than she has because
people are ashamed on the left of
success and privilege and so they even
flip humility and modesty true humility
does away with false modesty
but what these people are is really
prideful they're really prideful and
they don't want to admit the privileges
that they've had they don't want to be
thankful for it they don't want to
aspire to even greater privileges they
want to flip it they want to say no no I
didn't have any leg up in life no no I
didn't know I'm I had it really hard my
mother washed more floors for less money
than your mother did that's what they
all say they've flipped success and
victimhood and victimhood today carries
a cachet this is why when you look
around at college campuses there has
been a hole what's called the the campus
rape epidemic so many of the biggest of
these stories the most widely read the
UVA story the gang rape story in Rolling
Stone so many of the high profile
stories have proven to be hoaxes the
Duke Lacrosse one obviously mattress
girl at Columbia on and on there was a
we did a show about a month or two ago
where we went through about a dozen of
these why is it that all these huge
stories turn out to be hoaxes because
victimhood carries a cachet
it carries a social currency people want
it they think it makes them more
virtuous and this is our new vision of
the world from the left this isn't how
the right views things and this is
creating a real division it's why Howard
Schultz's candidacy with
probably hand the election to Donald
Trump so thank you Howard
but also it would be quite instructive
to America because I do think there are
people who are traditionally on the left
or traditionally Democrats who say gosh
they're really getting everything
backwards here gosh I don't I don't want
to live in a world where victimhood is
something to aspire to maybe and and so
his candidacy I think will show that
Fisher in the Democrat Party the trouble
for him is that the people who think
that I think are just gonna vote for
Trump I don't think that they're gonna
vote for Howard Schultz it's it's that
issue the sort of I'm a fiscal
conservative but a social liberal that
we were talking about yesterday the
actual people who want that very narrow
appeal are pretty small but the people
who are traditionally Democrats they
consider themselves progressive they
don't care about sexual issues they
don't they haven't really thought
through pro-life they whatever they're
just they're they they want to be
reasonable they see the the left right
now spiraling down and you know things
happen slowly and then they happen all
at once and I think we're seeing me all
at once part of that now you had over
time the Kesha identity politics
multiculturalism okay now this has
certain privileges or bad okay do to do
to do and now we're spiraling down into
this subjectivism this idea that we have
to invent our own pain we have to invent
our own realities you even had then
Anthony Kennedy when he was on the
Supreme Court say that people have a
right to define reality but of course
nobody has the right to define reality
you're entitled to your opinion but it's
might be incorrect you don't get to
define and you certainly don't get to
define it for everybody else we're
seeing that all at once and it leads us
into grievance studies this is a
phenomenon it's happened to colleges
where they're not studying history
philosophy English whatever math they're
studying ethnicity and gender studies
studies studies studies and it's really
just ideology it's not a traditional
academic discipline and it becomes more
and more ridiculous my guests coming up
Peter Bogosian and Jim Lindsey submitted
a number of academic papers
to peer-reviewed academic journals and
seven of them have been accepted
I think another seven of them were
accepted but not published or revise and
resubmit or whatever actually even more
than that only a few of them were
rejected before I think it was actually
a conservative journalist pointed out
that these were probably fake and they
exposed a major flaw in the Academy a
major flaw in our grievance culture we
will get to them in just one second but
first let's introduce a new sponsor and
thank our new sponsor for keeping the
lights on in the show on the air
Valentine's Day is fast approaching so
you need to know about halo you need to
check out a product called indulgences
dot store indulgences na komm dot store
what are you gonna do for Valentine's
Day I've been caught on this flowers
often or disappointing they're way
overpriced by Valentine's Day they often
come and they're all wilted they only
last for a few days so then you say okay
let me get some chocolates or something
but then you hear I can't eat chocolates
I'm too fat I don't they're gonna
they're fattening I will eat one then
you throw out the rest of the box this
year do something original and indulgent
for Valentine's Day something that rings
the bell at indulgences dot store not
calm dust or you can together with halo
healthy tribes create an C an indulgent
line of hot beverage mixes you just add
water for some of the most sumptuous
mugs of hot cocoa and other flavors they
have mazaru matcha yogi goji pink velvet
whole lotta lovin ooh I love me a good
pun I love it almost as much as I like a
mug of cocoa it's great it's 100%
natural too no added sugar they're
loaded with MCT oil in addition to being
100% natural they're just terrific
Organic 30.com called MCT oil the newest
healthy fat nutrition craze it's just
they're really advantageous for you and
for your health they bypass the small
intestine they're metabolized directly
into the body they're there it's a
similar if you've heard of bulletproof
coffee the MCT oil is the driving
ingredient there
these indulgent beverages are available
in Valentine's Day gift packages
starting as low as 39 bucks but step up
and be a man indulge her with all six
flavors were save even more and enroll
her in the subscription program to get
12 additional flavors it's just great if
you enter
kofi facio vfe Fe at checkout you save
10% if you order before February third
you'll also save $5 off shipping and
handling act quickly save money get the
Valentine's Day gift covered she will
love it it'll last for month indulgences
dot store promo code offa CoV fe fe 10%
off indulgences dot store do it now
don't be caught on Valentine's Day promo
code cough FAC OV e fe fe that's
indulgences with an S at the end that
store let's get to our guests
Peter Jim thank you for being here and
thanks for having us on you two are my
heroes and I should point out you're not
conservatives you're not Christians
you are both left-wing you are both
atheists Greta is absolutely correct
and yet we agree we completely agree you
are an inspiration to me because what
we're talking about is reality all right
you you guys have very different views
of reality than I do
religious truth political reality and
yet we're at least talking about reality
and that's that's the big difference
here between us and the intersectional
crowd who believes that a paper titled
human reactions to rape culture and
queer performativity at urban dog parks
in Portland Oregon could be a real
peer-reviewed not only not only but also
honored for exemplary scholarship and
feminist geography congratulations thank
you very much but we should explain to
people who don't know what peer-review
is what peer review is so peer review is
a system where we try to where academics
want to make sure that the scholarly
research is up to scratch so the idea
would be I want to write a paper I've
done my research I've read things that
maybe I did an experiment maybe I did
this and before I'm gonna publish that
papers yeah I'm not going on my blog and
putting it out there before I publish
that paper I'm gonna send it to other
experts in the field who know their
stuff ideally they're not going to know
who I am I'm not going to know who they
are so there's no conflict of interest
involved that's blind peer review which
is the standard now and they're gonna go
through my paper and they're gonna say
this parts okay this part is bad this
part needs fixing have you considered
these these insights did you
the right statistical methods did you
use the correct logic to get to the
conclusion they're gonna go through and
pick my paper apart for everything
that's wrong with it while giving some
constructive positive feedback as well
and then I'm gonna have to fix up my
paper and make sure that other experts
in the field at least two sometimes four
or more are going to check off and say
yeah this paper actually meets scholarly
credentials and deserves to be published
a scholarship and then they'll make a
recommendation to the journal editor who
says ah real experts that know this
field well recognize this as a
contribution and so papers that have
passed peer review that have been
accepted as a genuine contribution to
scholarship written by you guys under
pseudonyms would include who are they to
judge overcoming Anthrop anthropometry
and a framework for fat body building as
well as going in through the back door
challenging straight male homo hysteria
and transphobia through receptive
penetrative sex toy use yeah that one's
got a lot of big words let me sum that
one down for you a little bit boil that
down it was it straight men are
transphobic clearly and they can fix
that by putting things in their butt and
they thought this is a great idea it's
brilliant I mean it was not genuine
contribute and you guys you're a
mathematician you are a philosopher you
you are in the background refugees from
the Academy yeah are you experiencing
professional kickback from this you
published this hoax right it's it had to
be done you were had you are exposing
this shallow ridiculous academic culture
what's the ramification well piece many
many people have been incredibly
supportive and many people from all
across the political spectrum people I
get for example emails it might seem odd
that I is an evangelical Christian or
writing in support of the author of a
manual for creating atheists but I want
to say that I support you or
conservatives will will chime in on that
so there has been a lot of support the
administration is one might say not too
happy they're less supportive there
thank you that was lovely there's a
wonderful politic answer they're less
supportive of me in this context yeah
now what you have done is actually a
great service to the Academy there was a
crisis of the Academy we saw just in
psychology there was that replication
crisis a few years ago they couldn't
replicate all of these studies their
peer review by the way for those of you
who have friends in academia has been so
abused
very often it's professors pass this
down to grad students who skim who let
the nonsense go through this is a major
crisis and one of the biggest issues is
I notice as as a millennial a lot of
millennial friends Millennials are
supposedly the most educated generation
in history and they certainly have the
most degrees the most credentials most
of them go to college and yet they might
be the most ignorant generation I've
ever come across how does that work what
is the conflict well if it depends on
what they're being taught and how
they're being challenged right to become
truly educated means not just to be
exposed to lots and lots of courses but
to be exposed to relevant ideas within
your field but also challenging ideas
that make you think outside of your
field I see there's actually this kind
of internet subculture movement building
up to try to find an alternative to the
University and I don't like it
personally I think that the idea of the
University in its in its essence should
be that you as same as peer review you
have experts who guide students and
challenge their thinking give them
viewpoints that they don't agree with
and make them work through how they
might understand that perspective better
and if it's wrong they should learn to
articulate the arguments for why it's
wrong and if it's right then they can
try to work through some of that but
there's been this increasing
institutionalization of a certain kind
of thought that our papers are really
trying to dig into is that there's a
certain you know shallowness like you
were saying to if we're gonna talk about
issues of cultural relevance like race
or gender or so on then then you don't
have to you just know the right answer
you know it's it's this is this is the
right answer
if you'd put that on your on your test
you get the grade and if you don't you
don't so
you have this problem and then you go
into two institutionalizing that into
the general education requirement
instead of say something like civics or
Western civilization I I had to take
American history many of my friends were
dependent on a degree at my school what
a party at a school would make you take
American history yeah oh it was required
for every degree except engineering and
they had to take Western Civ if I don't
know why but whatever yeah and so these
are these were things that were
happening before but now you can fill
this in with you know Asian Studies or
somesuch
and so there's there's a degree of that
happening I'm sure there have also been
you know other factors not to put it all
on like grievance studies because for
example when I was finishing my degree
they actually in my state which was
Tennessee by state mandate cut the
number of hours required for a
bachelor's degree so that more people
would be able to get them so there are
political factors as well right lowering
of standards and one of the things that
I've seen happen that I'm deeply
concerned about is that there's a lack
of intellectual diversity in the Academy
and I think it's a tremendous problem
when for example and I don't know this
is probably this may showcase the
difference of ours I don't know I've
never spoken to you about this but
person in my class had commented about
he does not believe global warming is
anthropogenic and he said and I thought
he was this is a great point it's
totally legitimate why should we believe
this we we already know that the
overwhelming majority of professors are
you've proven it they adhere to a
radical leftist intersectional worldview
they're the same folks writing this so
why why should I
why should I believe that right there
ability is so in question yes so that's
why we need more diversity in the
Academy and that's why we need to look
at the scholarship that comes out we
need something to rely upon and we can't
do that now in this to your point before
I I love the University I like the idea
of the University to use yeah John Henry
Newman sprays I don't want to give up
the University to these lunatics who are
attacking it from within so you've come
in and taken a stand and it's worth
pointing out to what grievin
Studies is because you come from
philosophy you come from mathematics
I majored in history these are liberal
arts these are now increasingly in
universities you'll have new departments
women's gender studies in it it's any of
the studies there's a kind of irony here
because whenever there are these new
stuff Women's Studies gays studies
whatever studies this studies always
likes and approves of the thing that
it's studying except for American
Studies that is the one Studies
department that actually despises the
object of its studies when did these
crop up when did the deputy assistant
dean of inclusion and sexual studies
when did this happen and start gutting
or a university how surprised you're
going to be to find out it was the late
1960s but really that was part of it
there is the big cultural kind of change
that was happening in the late 60s and
going into the 70s you know following
civil rights and all of this and the
university really wanted to be on the
vanguard of that they wanted to showcase
diversity and they wanted to have more
scholars that there were women and there
were racial minorities and try to be on
the forefront of making a more diverse
professional class hey hey ho ho Western
Civ has got to go but not quite yet
around but yeah now and what happened
was they started to create these kind of
boutique departments around very
politically fashionable ideas like
women's studies feminist studies race
studies etc and because of a number of
factors that can get pretty complicated
and it's a lot of inside baseball they
never really got challenged exactly they
also simultaneously picked up a very
fashionable postmodern deconstructive
philosophy for for doing their stuff so
this is what I want to actually get to
because I I saw dear old Yale crumbling
during just my four years there I saw
this really pick up fast I mean you had
kids screaming at their professors by
the time I graduated one thing I noticed
is that we all agree on reality we all
agree that reality exists exactly we're
arguing over these facts there's also
this radical subjectivism
yeah which says there's no truth there's
your truth and my price where does that
idea come from and where is that leading
us and how do we fight that well you
know we don't you can answer that yeah
that question the deep answers that's
that's postmodern deconstruction it goes
back to the 60s these French
philosophers the the the narrow enters
in the late 80s and 90s it took a turn
you had race scholars like kimberlé
crenshaw and Gender scholars like Judith
Butler who are saying things like we
know identity must be real because
oppression based on identity is real and
if we want to change things we want to
have effective activism perfect
progressive activism we need to admit
that those are real and then continue to
use our deconstructive methods to
deconstruct the conversations around
those objects so we agree on reality
existing and we mean one particular
thing by it they would say they agree
that reality exists also but that it's
rooted in the one real thing is
oppression based on identify which has
always been the moral pression the clear
view of reality yeah this is such a
brilliant observation I have never heard
this before but you have explained it
sometimes when I'm on college campuses
people ask me they say how is it that
the the intersectional Left can so
embrace identity as this absolute but
then they become subjectivist when it
gets to identity a man can be a woman a
white lady can be a black lady it's all
kind of fluid and your answer is because
of the reality of the oppression right
so as long as you can claim victimhood
as long as you can claim oppression mmm
the details of the identity from which
you get the oppression that's all
malleable it's just all about the
oppression the grievance the this and
the more oppression variables one has
the clearer view of reality standpoint
epistemology which is a kind of related
thing to another thing called critical
constructivist epistemology this all has
like real deep these real academic stuff
right we call the critical
constructivist epistemology grievance
studies well it's a little bit easier to
grasp what's going on there and the idea
with these I especially standpoint
epistemology is that there's always a
power dynamic
and if you're on the up side of the
power dynamic you are let's say a man
who lives in a man's world so you have
one perspective man and man but if
you're a woman who lives in a man's
world now you have the woman perspective
and because you live in the man's world
you have the man perspective too
therefore you know more things right
plus you get to claim oppression and
victimhood and you add another variable
to that black yeah disabled they get
man's even more more moral a strong
objectivity yes Sandra Harding called
that yeah you get more access to know
the truth in your personal subjective
experience by having oppression in it I
mean as a Christian that must be
horrific truly shocking our world is
upside down right this is so interesting
though and it's why I love that real
academic people such as yourselves did
this hoax because the hoax is it's
really funny and Ethne in ethnography of
breastaurant masculinity themes of
objectification sexual conquest and
masculine toughness in a sexually
objectifying restaurant that was
accepted and published I mean just a
wonderful our struggle is my struggle
solidarity feminism is an intersectional
reply to neoliberal and choice feminism
this is a writer of mine calm that's a
chapter of mine Kampf by Adolf Hitler
right I mean these are really funny but
it's not just a haha look how ridiculous
the other side is right they do have a
coherent train of thought yeah
absolutely
perverse these aren't even actually
hoaxes we started with hoaxes we failed
to get hoaxes in the first six papers we
wrote all failed they couldn't get in so
we started to actually learn how they
think and write the papers in accordance
with what really is grievance studies we
became grievance scholars ourselves in a
sense and we learn to think like they do
we understood their comic book universe
where you know sometimes people can fly
or whatever and we wrote accordingly and
then we uncovered some pretty serious
issues so they have this tight ecosystem
incoherence and philosophy call it
coherence theory all these nodes in a
matrix of a belief they all cohere
together and it's it does make an echo
system and the
man Superman yeah it's like do you sleep
in the Batman universe right Batman can
do a lot of cool stuff but he can't fly
so if you wanted to write a fan comic
and you make Batman fly everybody's
gonna be like what he needs like a hang
glider right right right
of course yes and this unfortunately
we're out of time and I have to let
people know where to find you on twitter
at peter Bogosian gym you can find on
twitter at conceptual james there's a
documentary coming out I think there's
later this year Mike naina
Mike Nana's doing a documentary on on
this which is I'm glad you brought this
up here at the end it isn't a hoax what
you have done is gone in identified not
just how the grievance studies illogic
thinks but you have gotten these these
papers peer-reviewed and published you
buy recognized for excellence recognized
for excellence you you really it is
outrageous to call it a hoax you could
call the whole field a hoax right but
you couldn't call what you have done a
hoax you it is so important if we want
to combat this nonsense if we want to
try to save the university save liberal
education you have to be able to
actually understand how these people
think how they have gone so wrong in
their trains of thought only then can
you come back and get back and to a sane
reality we very much want to restore
confidence in the Academy and that
confidence and Trust has been eroded not
only in the peer-review system but in
the whole Academy the whole
institutional structure I think I think
you're doing God's work both of you
atheists thank you so much for hanging
here appreciate it Jim we got to go
great to have you thank you so much
great thank you
those are the first guys who could
explain to me some of the contradictions
within the intersectional Left I hope
people pay attention to them because
they've really got an insight here that
explains so much of the craziness and
all the shrieking kids on college
campuses and all the other nonsense
flitting about our culture we've got a
lot more to get to we've got to get to
Kamala Harris that that seductress
Kamala Harris launching her political
career apparently with a married man
but before we get to that it's time for
you to get on the right side of history
which is in fact the title of Ben
Shapiro's new book it officially hits
stores March 19th but if you go to right
side of history
you can order your copy right now before
they sell out do it you will thank me
later
ah it pains me to say nice things about
been earnestly on the show but I have to
do it the book is very good the book is
really really good I read an early draft
of it and so he's I think even punched
it up a little bit since then and it was
excellent
I read all these books that come at all
these popular books many of which are
not very good and bins is like the
answer to that book I hope it sells a
zillion copies it would be really
helpful to the culture so go check it
out ok I won't say any more in earnest
nice things about Ben go to daily
wire.com so much more to get to but you
got to go it's 10 bucks a month 100
ollars for an annual membership you get
me you get the end replevin sure you get
the Ben Shapiro show you get as
questions the mailbag you get the Matt
Walsh show it has questions on backstage
which is coming up you'll get to ask Oh
get your mailbag questions in by the way
for tomorrow you get to see another
Kingdom you get everything you get this
this is the mmm you know what this is
this is the Pike Place roast of leftist
tears this is that Howard Schultz is
gonna reelect Donald Trump and spoil it
for the Democrats sort of mmm you know
some people say that that Pike Place is
bitter I think it's just perfectly sweet
yum yum it's sweet and salty in the
leftist ears tumblr it's like kettle
corn of some sort go to daily we're calm
we'll be right back
all of this talk about grievance
politics has got me feeling aggrieved
and I am feeling aggrieved because
Hillary Clinton is not running for
president Jeff Zeleny is reporting that
Hillary Clinton is not closing the door
on running for 2020 do you think she
would actually do it well you know I
take her at her word I don't she's not
running for president
she's not running for president this is
according to John Podesta her spirit
cooking warlock of a former campaign
chairman it sounds like Hillary is out
now of course when Hillary Clinton says
she's not running for president there's
still a 98 point eight eight nine seven
percent chance that she is running for
president because Hillary Clinton has
been running for president since she was
five years old but unfortunately it
sounds like she's not going to run it's
too bad fortunately for us we have
Hillary Clinton 4.0 also known as Kamala
Harris who is running so yesterday we
showed a clip of Kamala Harris endorsing
Medicare for all the most extreme
socialist form of health care here is
her endorsing it with Jake Tapper
correct me if I'm wrong to reiterate you
support the Medicare for all bill I
think initially co-sponsored by Senator
Bernie Sanders you're also a co-sponsor
I believe it will totally eliminate
private insurance so for people out
there who like their insurance what they
don't get to keep it
well the listen the idea is that
everyone gets access to medical care and
you don't have to go through the process
of going through an insurance company
having them give you approval going
through the paperwork all of the delay
that may require who of us has not had
that situation where you got to wait for
approval and the doctor says well I
don't know if your insurance company is
going to cover this
let's eliminate all of that let's move
on let's eliminate all that let's move
on this is Kamala Harris that was her
yesterday I guess the CNN ran that
article they ran that clip because it
was aired on CNN they then updated the
article this came out this morning they
said quote as the furor grew not the
former leader of Nazi Germany fewer fu
RoR as the furor grew a Harris advisor
on Tuesday signaled that the candidate
would also be open to the
moderate health reform plans which would
preserve the industry being floated by
other congressional Democrats it
represents a compromise position that
risks angering medicare-for-all
proponents who view eliminating private
health insurance as key to enacting
their comprehensive reform so what does
this mean Kamala Harris comes out there
and says yeah let's destroy 1/6 of the
American economy let's just eliminate it
boom gone and obviously those companies
as private insurers private health care
providers people who like having choice
in their health care there was huge
blowback there and so Kamala Harris says
okay okay well maybe I didn't quite mean
that now this is how we know that she's
Hillary Clinton 4.0 is she's a
weathervane whatever way the wind is
blowing she's gonna do it she began her
career according to former San Francisco
Mayor Willie Brown by dating a married
man that came out yesterday a married
man who was like 20 or 30 years older
than her he said yesterday the guy who
did this married man dates Kamala Harris
and says oh yes yeah I dated her and
then as a result I put her on some
influential committees and look where
she is today
this is a woman who will do whatever it
takes to become president the kind of
woman who launches her career that way
with a older married man is the kind of
person who will do whatever it takes and
so maybe that means tacking all the way
to the left if that seems like the way
that the winds are blowing maybe that
means moderating 24 hours later if
that's the way that the winds are
blowing obviously it is crazy it's crazy
to eliminate 1/6 of the economy to take
that over a CNN is actually correct in
its coverage the medicare-for-all
so-called the socialist health care
advocates they do view any private
insurance as an impediment to their
utopian solution to their plan I mean
they are radicals they are Jacobins
they are the ones who are speeding
hurtling toward a totalitarian utopian
future and so they see if anyone else
has any control over health care be it
the patient's be it the doctors via the
insurance providers be it any market
forces that is an impediment to them
having total
control over your health and if you've
got control over people's health you've
got control over people this is why
making the health care industry
socialist why a government takeover of
health care is different in kind from
takeovers of other industries it would
also be a big deal if the government
took over the oil industry would be a
big deal if they took over the computer
industry be a big deal if they took over
those industries - Healthcare is
something special because it's about
your life it's about life and death it's
about your health and if they have
control over that people don't always
make the most rational choices they
don't oh wait this is actually how these
socialists have been able to infect the
healthcare system is they say well the
markets for buying a new computer the
markets for buying a new car are very
different from the markets when you're
deciding which medical tests to take
they have a certain point we do care
more about our health and we care about
which car we drive but nevertheless
human nature doesn't change and when you
can see costs when you can see
incentives when you can have freedom to
choose what kind of care you want to get
you are going to make choices by
definition that are more tailored to you
to your preferences to your health than
if some government bureaucrat doesn't
but that's what they're playing on
that's what the Socialists are
exploiting it's a real vulnerability so
Kamala Harris knows tacking back to the
other end why she's responding in many
ways to Howard Schultz and she's
responding to Mike Bloomberg Mike
Bloomberg and other zillionaire for my
former mayor of New York who was a
Republican for five minutes but he's
really a lifelong moderate Democrat and
a nanny state kind of guy he banned
smoking in New York he's wants to ban
guns he's just a billionaire elitist I
know better than you I'm your benevolent
better sort of guy I mean he's got the
Howard Schultz vibe to him and he says
quote I think you could never afford
Medicare for all
you're talking about trillions of
dollars to replace the entire private
system where companies provide health
care for their employees would bankrupt
us for a very long time it's just not a
practical thing yes of course that's
true so Kamala Harris today is swinging
back you got to remember the
2020 race has not even really begun yet
there are a lot of undeclared candidates
right now not many candidates have
declared and we're gonna see which way
the wind blows I mean politics has been
pretty volatile for the last two years
if in the course of one week we can tack
back to the center say we're going to
preserve private insurance no we're
gonna have pure socialist single-payer
government-run health care no back and
forth we're gonna see and and what is
going to define which way it blows or
the candidates who are in this race and
when you've got twenty candidates in the
race plus at least one independent
Democrat in Howard Schultz maybe two
independent Democrats in Mike Bloomberg
they're going to define it's gonna be
very volatile and and we're gonna see
you know the only thing we can predict
right now is that we can't predict
anything if you had asked a year out
from the 2016 election who was going to
be the Republican nominee very few
people would have told you Donald Trump
and he in so many ways to find that
election he pushed the bigger the bigger
issues of immigration he pushed the
issues of defeating Isis he pushed the
issues of building a wall securing our
country even economic protection he
pushed all of those things which were
not really at the forefront before him
Kamala Harris is obviously not gonna be
the leader here
she's the follower she's the Hillary
Clinton she's not gonna set the tone she
is gonna be the weathervane but if a
candidate is bolder than Kamala Harris
and can have the courage to set the tone
probably that's going to be the person
who's going to be leading in the field
that's going to be the person that other
people are going to follow
unfortunately for Democrats right now
they have a whole field of cowards they
don't have anyone you know for all of
her wackiness and wicked ideology
Alexandria Ocasio Cortes would be a
candidate that people could rally behind
on the Democrat Party it's no
coincidence that 74% of Democrats say
they would vote for her for president
thank goodness me Robbie lady - she's
too young to run right now but but I
think that's the sort of thing that our
present politics is gonna reward Kamala
Harris is a pretty smart candidate but
if she doesn't get a little bit bolder
she's gonna fall way behind which also
wouldn't be a terrible thing there is we
talked about all the good news in pop
culture yesterday as it relates to
abortion
people finally realizing that babies are
babies even while politicians like New
York's Andrew Cuomo legalized the
wholesale slaughter of babies the pop
culture TV shows their kind of
understanding it now they're even making
dark jokes about how babies are babies
this is not the case with the
transgender ideology Kate Hudson last
week came out and said she was gonna
raise her daughter genderless she said
quote I think you just raise your kids
individually regardless like a
genderless approach we still don't know
what she's going to identify as I will
say that right now she's incredibly
feminine in her energy her sounds and
her way probably because it was talking
about a baby girl that's probably why
she's feminine if she or a baby boy she
probably wouldn't be feminine she
wouldn't be a she so now she's coming in
and saying I'm not gonna raise my
daughter genderless which I don't does
she want mother of the year for that
does she want a cookie
um you're I'm not gonna abuse my child
oh great good ray good job you know
she's saying she was taken out of
context by clickbait websites but she
wasn't you heard the quote she said it
that was what she said and she's buying
into a popular culture that pushes this
I don't watch the show Supergirl because
I'm a person and therefore I don't watch
nobody watches the show but there was a
clip going around of it where one of the
characters is describing coming from the
alien planet null tour but that isn't
what really defines her identity so when
did your mom come from Elton when she
was 18 the night before she fled her
planet she had a dream about a farmhouse
where she would meet her true love and
she saw a bunch of random coordinates
that she plugged into her craft and she
landed on earth and parthis a human
family took her in farmer's
and she fell in love with their son my
dad Wow
yeah I can't imagine having grown up
anywhere else because you have parents
from two different planets yeah but also
because I'm trans I always knew that I
was a girl my parents were amazing they
affirmed my authentic self and helped me
transition young and I've always been
able to be open about who I was in
parthis I'm not saying as easy there
were definitely people who didn't
understand but the town's ethos of
inclusion is strong and I think if I
grew up anywhere else it would have been
a lot tougher thank you for sharing that
with me of course this is actually a
pretty insightful scene I mean it's
absurdly written it's not good art in
any way but it's pretty insightful in
its ideology because it is in fact the
case that transgenderism is just as real
as the alien planet null tour they are
exactly as real they have exactly as
much to do with reality science fiction
and reality are now indistinguishable on
the left there's no difference why is
this in part I think this is because as
we always say politics is downstream of
culture culture comes from the cult and
the religion and what one worships and
so we have myths we have founding myths
in our civilization myths that seem to
bear out throughout many civilizations
the same kinds of stories the echoes of
our ancient past come out throughout all
these various societies why because they
tell us something about our human nature
and then in the case of Christianity
Christianity is the true myth it is
where myth and the literal world
coincide in a person in a place in a
time who in the incarnation and in the
crucifixion and the resurrection when
when those are the stories real and and
mythological that define your world you
have a certain civilization you have
what what would have been Western
civilization until our postmodern era
but now that that is gone now that
religiosity is on the wane the nuns are
up and unn
culture generation basically ignorant
generation has risen up
we still need stories and so we fill
them with kind of weird science fiction
now the only myths people talk about or
Harry Potter or science fiction the only
movies people go see or the superhero
movies they're the they're the only
movies to dominate at the box office
the popular culture is very influential
and right now this transgender question
is all threat pop culture where it's on
orange is the new black transparent I am
Kate tangerine a fantastic woman the
Danish girl on Anna there were like 10
people who are confused about their
gender in the country and there are 10
pieces of pop culture that come out
every year on this question when the
culture is saturated people become numb
so now it seems perfectly normal it
seems perfectly normal to I mean first
of all that isn't a transgender girl or
man or any you know that's a that's a
female
that's an actress that's talking about
this but it becomes numb we say there's
really no difference between men and
women and so we start confusing children
we start injecting them with hormones as
this scene as advocating we start
putting kids in drag and having men at
bars throw dollar bills at them as is
happening now we we begin to abuse
children it seems perfectly natural to
us because we have we just have these
narratives swirling around but the
narratives aren't true they come from
false myths they come from false his
stories and false ideas everybody's got
to serve somebody and either you will
ground your view of the world in reality
in in in real fact in true myths and in
the myths or you will fall into fantasy
and fantasy when you live out of
accordance with reality it has really
terrible effects for people for society
for politics all around that's our show
get your mailbag questions then in the
meantime I'm Michael nose this is the
Michael Nolt show I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Robert Sterling executive producer
Jeremy more senior producer Jonathan hey
our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico
audio is mixed by Dylan case hair and
makeup is by Jessa
all Vera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Michael Noel's show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19